[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
une rentrée sous Omicron le vario est
devenu majoritaire dans la plupart des
pays européens vous allez le voir sur
cette carte 96 % des cas au Royaume-Uni
sont justement décontamination allô
Mikron 92 % en Irlande 75 % au Portugal
plus de 62 % en France vous le voyez
donc avec près de 200400 min à Sion par
jour la France Miss toujours sur la
vaccination une accélération du rappel
vaccinal et la mise en place d'un
passeport vaccinal à partir du 15
janvier le texte de loi est examiné en
ce moment à l'Assemblée nationale
l'omicron va entraîner une
désorganisation du lieu de travail ainsi
que des écoles les quarantaine sont
néanmoins allégé pour ne pas mettre le
pays à l'arrêt la durée d'isolement et
ramener de 7 voir 5 jours pour les
personnes infectées il y a un parcours
vaccinal complet la rentrée sous Omicron
c'est donc le thème de ce débat le micro
est-il moins dangereux que le delta quel
impact dans l'eau citation du travail
quelle conséquence sur les écoles
comment d'autres pays combattent-ils le
virus nous irons en Israël mais aussi en
Allemagne et puis quel impact sur la
campagne présidentielle française et
puis finalement quel le sentirais après
2 ans de virus on en parle avec mes
invités par skype de Bruxelles Yves
copier tes recettes avec nous à Bonsoir
médecin épidémiologiste à l'Université
Libre de Bruxelles également professeur
de santé publique directeur du centre de
recherche épidémiologie et
biostatistique de l'école de santé
publique de l'ULB avec toi également
dans la première partie des missions
Stéphanie ma te dis bonsoir à vous
également bienvenue directrice formation
et dialogue social à alixio également
présidente de art du dialogue social
vous êtes donc avec nous et puis
Gwendoline de Bono nous a été avec nous
également correspondante correspondant
au nom de France 24 à Jérusalem Bonsoir
Gwendoline
Bonsoir alors avant de commencer cette
discussion je propose d'écouter les
propos rassurant de Olivier Véran
ministre de la Santé sur justement c'est
varié au micro-ondes peut-être encore
une fois tu t'es peut-être la dernière
des vagues c'est-à-dire que vu le taux
de contamination dans notre pays et
d'ailleurs dans la sur la planète il est
probable que nous ayons tous à King
forme d'immunité ou par la vaccination
ou par d'infection ou les deux
aujourd'hui on va avoir à l'issue de la
vague au micro une qui sera largement
supérieur à 50 % même avec la
vaccination quasiment du sang pour sang
réalité
au micro-ondes serait-il pourrait-il
être le dernier variant
ah ça c'est compliqué à répondre alors
c'est vrai que c'est un va rien en fait
qui arrive sur des populations
européennes en fait avec une forte
imiter imiter acquise par la vaccination
les deux lettres à dos et puis une
immunité acquise aussi par les
différentes vagues successives et
surtout la dernière vague du Var et
c'est vrai que Omicron arrive et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y a un
échappement et militaire de microbes
partiel il essaie d'arriver de prendre
le devant et sur le bar mais il arrive
pas c'est une population dans lequel il
y a un mur lié à une unité de base à
Kizou poste de vaccination qui est
j'aurais l'empêche fortement entre en
tout cas d'évoluer avec une forte
létalité est-ce qu'on pourra s'attendre
collective malgré le fait que justement
la vaccination est encore très inégal
dans le monde
du monde ça va être compliqué sauf que
Omicron va faire encore une pars du
boulot entre guillemets puisque il va
aussi toucher fortement différents types
de population il est très content Amina
on a compris et puis il va développer
une humilité et
les formes cliniques je dirais à se
modérer en tout cas par rapport au petit
à petit on est petit à petit dans un
cycle de nouveau mutant qui va arriver
face à des populations de mieux en mieux
immunisé et c'est Marion en chaque fois
je dirais s'adapter en terme surtout de
contamination et puis face à limiter pas
fatalement je dirais létalité sera moins
fort donc vous êtes optimiste comme
Olivier Véran ce qui nous vous proposons
pas choqué vous êtes plutôt d'accord
avec lui alors ces propos ne sont pas
choquant vu je lirai les connaissances
qu'on a sur les effets de micro et on le
voit très bien sur les hospitalisations
même si un sursaut des hospitalisation
en Angleterre un tout petit peu au
Danemark mais je dirais que l'effet je
dirais de la létalité les formes grave
et quand même nettement au moindre que
pour les avoir
est-ce que tout à fait encourageant
c'est que il y a très peu d'influence
sur la mortalité on peut être optimiste
en tout cas à part au micro mais non je
pense que nos politiques ont toujours un
regard l' entrée sur leur leur contexte
leur environnement leur pays et je pense
qu'il faut quand même un peu
international à ce stade si même si on
va fortement aider nos politiques à
gérer cette épidémie
en Israël Jérusalem puisqu'on parle à
Jérusalem Israël qui avait mis la
première première campagne de
vaccination en place et d'ailleurs on
démarre la 4e dose aujourd'hui
Gwendoline
oui absolument et c'est aussi le pays
qui prend en premier cette décision à
d'administrer une quatrième dose
effectivement depuis ce matin les plus
de 60 ans ainsi que les membres du
personnel médical peuvent recevoir cet
4e dose de vaccin si leur 3e dose elle
date d'il y a au moins 4 mois alors
l'idée d'administrer cette 4e dose au
plus fragile c'est vraiment de les
protéger face à la fulgurance un de de
ce variant Omicron en Israël comme dans
d'autres pays alors avant cela est bien
il y a eu un essai clinique sur sur des
volontaires en Israël en essai clinique
avec qui a duré plusieurs semaines et il
n'a pas été constaté des effets
indésirables à court terme en tout cas
pas plus que pour la troisième dozo que
pour la deuxième dose mais c'est vrai
que la communauté sur des piques
israélienne reconnais qu'il y a assez
peu de recul sur cette 4e dos donc c'est
quelque part 1 Paris pour protéger les
plus fragiles encore une fois les plus
de 60 ans les personnes immunodéprimées
et les membres du personnel médical mais
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle est
bien cette 4e dose c'est une possibilité
elle mais c'est pas une recommandation
formelle et encore moins une obligation
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
est bien cette 4e dose il est possible
qu'elle reste est bien un rappel pour
les personnes les plus fragiles
d'ailleurs il n'est absolument pas
question en Israël pour l'instant de
l'étendre au reste de la population et
Gwendoline quel d'enseignement
finalement peut-on retirer de cette
expérience israélienne lo lo me
connaît-il moins grave justement en
Israël et ce constat qu'on peut faire
là-bas
alors ce qu'on constate c'est que
d'abord les contaminations à ces
dernières 24 heures on double et
aujourd'hui on assimile nouveau cas par
jour on estime et bien que la semaine
prochaine ce sera 20.000 nouveau par
jour donc cela va très vite pour
l'instant il y a 35000 personnes
atteintes du covid-19 en Israël et c'est
vrai qu'il y a assez peu de grave il y a
110 personnes qui sont hospitalisés dans
un état grave et la majorité de ces
personnes et bien elles ne sont pas
vacciné du tout c'est ce qui fait dire
aux autorités israélienne à la fois que
ce variant Omicron et peut-être moins
dangereux et moins dangereux que le
delta mais également que la troisième
dos que le troisième rappel de vaccin et
bien montre son efficacité car il
protège contre les formes grave du
covid-19 Stéphanie le mettre dans
l'univers du travail il y a un nouveau
protocole 3 jours obligatoire de
télétravail sous peine de sanction une
amende importante un pour les
récalcitrants
qui peut aller jusqu'à 1000 € salarié en
fonction du comportement de l'employeur
qui peut aller jusqu'à 50000 € alors
quelle est la réaction des entreprises
en France après l'annonce de ce
protocole
on fait les directions les DRH et les
partenaires sociaux effectivement un
gouvernement se sont rencontrés les
salariés l'ensemble sont devenu très
très Matic sur le sujet ils sont
fatigués sont un peu usé comme c'est
c'est c'est mondial mais ils sont prêts
et en fait chacun accepte cette couche
d'adaptation supplémentaire qui vit qui
est venu se surajouter est plutôt que de
que de voir effectivement le dispositif
se met en place comme à l'accoutumée
depuis 2 ans les situations de
télétravail est désormais connu reconnu
les moyens ont été mise en place dans la
plupart des entreprises qui a qui en
avait l'habitude donc on
rentre un petit peu dans un jeu pas dire
quotidien de chris un pain quotidien de
crise et effectivement il y a toujours
des récalcitrant parce que il y en a qui
aussi on des difficultés face à cette
situation de télétravail alors on
cherche aussi des aspects un peu
punitifs et lol l'aspect punitifs
effectivement c'est une amende de 1000 €
par salarié concerné dans la limite de
50000 € par entreprise qui n'est quand
même pas rien alors tout dépend du
modèle d'entreprise bien évidemment mais
plutôt que que de travailler sur cet
aspect punitive sur cet aspect défensif
on le sent bien vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
des des partenaires et des parties
prenantes sur ce cette spécificité de
contagion et d'épidémie c'est que c'est
surtout le l'intelligence collective et
le bon sens qui était en action on a pas
trop de plaintes on a pas trop de gens
qui se plaignent on a surtout des gens
qui souhaitent s'organiser le mieux
possible aussi bien dans les entreprises
que dans le secteur public on a pu voir
on prends exemple sur le modèle anglais
on s'aperçoit on prend aussi les
inquiétudes du monde et l'anglais et on
s'aperçoit que dans le secteur public
dans le secteur privé il peut y avoir
des disparités en
adaptation 2 7 2 7 plus difficile
parce que
l'entreprise on le voit en tout cas
c'est ce qui les inquiétudes tu étais
porter en Angleterre le secteur public
et moins réactive peut-être moins
réactive alors il faut qu'on l'observe
peut-être ça aussi dans notre pays ce
sera pas forcément le cas et on l'espère
que non mais c'est toujours plus
compliqué on le voit dans le domaine de
la santé ça se passe plutôt bien
c'est-à-dire que il y a des réactions il
y a des protocoles qui sont mises en
place des protocole d'urgence et on
dépasse finalement les conditions et ce
qui est imposé par le gouvernement qui
intervient plutôt en garant plutôt que
en gerent les entreprises ont une
dynamique un temps un temps d'avance
dans la réactivité parce que il faut
trouver des solutions de manière urgente
face à cette absentéisme qui va arriver
dans les 3 prochaines semaines dans les
entreprises dit de service les plus
importantes y a des protocoles de cri
ils sont organisés y a des plan de
continuité de l'activité de l'activité
qui sont organisés donc il y a déjà
assez pas il y a des choses qui ont été
organisé depuis 2 ans pour te rappelles
de ce qu'on connait déjà c'est un peu
sac et et l'intelligence collective est
vraiment important et on sent que chacun
trouve de des solutions il y a
énormément de dialogue il y a énormément
de communication sociale et les
solutions sont extrêmement différentes
selon que l'on soit dans une petite
structure une grosse voiture ou bien
évidemment dans le secteur de la santé
ou c'est là où effectivement c'est
l'adaptation est quasi permanente si un
maintien de poste de soignants qui est
positif mais asymptomatique qui a été
décidé dans certains hôpitaux pour tenir
parce que il faut il faut absolument
tenir et et soigner les malades
des services ont modifié le protocole on
s'adapte en permanence sans attendre
finalement les conditions donc c'est
assez je pense Unity bien sûr il est là
et bien sûr il fallait redonner du sens
à ceux qui ne respectent pas les le
télétravail mais pour autant on n'est
pas là-dedans complètement aujourd'hui
on est vraiment dans une réactivité une
adaptation fort tu es une intelligence
collective
et aussi les rassemblements un 2000
personnes à l'intérieur 4000 personnes à
l'extérieur c'est important c'est Jojo
ça concerne les concerts die
interdiction des concerts debout mais un
peu de tout tout rassemblement il faut
limiter les rassemblements il comprit à
l'extérieur
parce qu'en fait c'est une question
d'adaptation environnement
et
gestion de risque de
sécurité
je pense que des jours c'est intéressant
mais les appliquer telles qu'elles dans
tous les environnements et dans tous les
milieux culturel où les milieu sportif
ça n'a pas beaucoup de chance mais non
c'est vrai qu'il faut faire attention
aux microbes se répand très facilement
la population alors c'est vrai que si on
a bien dit en début d'entretien à qui
sait pas il faut pas avoir peur des
contaminations à tout prix il faut voir
quelle est l'influence sur le système de
soins de santé et sur les sur les
complications le système hospitalier
mais c'est vrai que on pourrait
peut-être changer de paradigme dans la
gestion de cette fille être plus dans
une gestion du risque et gestion du
risque c'est pas ce sont pas des choses
c'est chaque endroit qui définit sa
jauge en fonction de ce système de
ventilation de d'application des
barrières et autre système de protection
des personnes qui participent à
l'événement dans quelque chose de moi
nationale c'est ce que vous dites en
tout cas il y a pas de limitation de
jauge bien sûr pour les meeting de
campagne mais Valérie Pécresse par
exemple la candidate de droite et la
République en marche le faire respecter
les gens ils veulent également utiliser
le past vaccinal mais pas l'extrême
droite ni d'ailleurs les on va vous
allez écouter ce qu'on dit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon justement sur se passe
vaccinal que Valérie Pécresse et la
République en marche accepte en fait de
contrôler avant les meeting de campagne
dans les restaurants qui vend contrôler
l'identité mais dans quel monde
allons-nous vivre à la fin tout le monde
va contrôler tout le monde ça c'est une
société totalitaire une société
autoritaire voilà ce que c'est
[Musique]
pas
parce que vous aurez moins de liberté
les restrictions de liberté ont toujours
été de ceux qui croient l'efficacité du
tout de suite et sans discussion
Escoffier terre c'est ce que fictivement
restriction de liberté parce que
nécessiter pour la santé publique ou pas
assez compliqué le débat de se passe
sanitaire qui se transforme en passe
vaccinal
c'est vrai que par rapport à une
population très fortement vacciné et
celle de la France mais c'est le cas
aussi beaucoup d'autres pays européens
cette transformation du Pass vaccinal
peut être questionner en tout cas moi
sur un plan purement de santé publique
je ne je ne le défend pas parce que je
pense malheureusement il ne va pas
améliorer les choses en terme de clivage
la société et je pense pas que c' est
celle qui ne refuse à Clément se faire
vacciner bon il y a des rêves malgré
tout et lorsque on parle de passe de
maximale on entre dans une logique
plutôt a de moyens de long terme et donc
c'est ça qui est compliqué aussi je
passe aussi une obligation vaccinale
tout simplement en tout cas ce serait
beaucoup plus simple et c'est quelque
chose qu'on aurait pu être beaucoup plus
tôt alors je pense pas que c'est
l'obligation vaccinale de toute la
population et surtout vais sûrement pas
mais moins 18 ans mais quoi qu'il en
soit plus fort c'est les personnes
fragiles et vulnérable celles et ceux
qui sont à risque de d'entrée et aussi
encore avec son mari en micro de de se
faire vacciner alors est-ce qu on passe
on parle d'une vaccination obligatoire
chez les plus de 60 ans 70 ans ça c'est
ça c'est ça c'est une décision politique
mais c'est quelque chose qui aurait été
plus simple et qui à mon avis aurait des
impacts beaucoup plus fort en termes de
santé publique
correspondante en Allemagne de line
toujours en Israël ils ont fermer les
frontières mais alors maintenant les
touristes vacciné peuvent revenir la
semaine prochaine me semble-t-il donc
finalement le pays revient sur sa
fermeture des frontières
oui absolument d'abord il faut souvenir
qui serait en fait tu avais fermé ses
frontières aux touristes depuis le début
de la pandémie et puis le pays a décidé
de les rouvrir début novembre ça n'a
tenu car moi tout juste un mois puisque
après il y a eu l'arrivée est bien de se
voit rien Omicron alors cela change
effectivement la semaine prochaine à
partir du 9 janvier les touristes
vacciné pourront revenir dans le pays à
condition qu'ils ne viennent pas d'un
pays qui est classé sur la liste dit
rouge en Israël alors pour l'instant les
États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne ou encore
les Émirats arabes unis font toujours
partie de cette liste rouge mais tout de
même cela laisse la possibilité aux
touristes vacciner pour leur majorité de
de revenir alors Naftali Bennett a
reconnu que cette décision pouvaient
sembler contre-intuitive un peu la
fulgurance du vario micro-ondes en
Israël mais en fait c'est exactement
pour cette raison que les frontières
vont ouvrir à partir du 9 janvier à
partir de la semaine prochaine parce
qu'il y a tellement de en mais là on
estime et bien que que d'ici la fin du
mois il pourrait y avoir jusqu'à 2
million de personnes malades il y a
tellement de cas que ce n'est pas
l'arrivée de touristes potentiellement
malade qui peuvent changer quelque chose
à cela et c'est pour ça que cette
décision a été prise au revanche cela va
changer beaucoup de choses pour les
acteurs du tourisme qui bien évidemment
souffre beaucoup depuis le début de la
pandémie les acteurs du tourisme du
tourisme pardon israélien mais également
les acteurs du tourisme palestinien
puisque quand il sera elle prend la
décision de fermer ses frontières et
bien de facto les territoires
palestiniens sont et aussi inaccessible
donc on part et aussi là-bas sur une
possibilité 10 minutes et collectives
Stéphanie Matuidi pour regarder un petit
peu généraliser un petit peu le propos
sur le marché du travail est-ce que
finalement il a durablement changer ce
marché du travail depuis le début du
covit vide et vous parlez d'adaptation
permanente mais il a durablement changer
bah il y a certains secteurs bien
évidemment que tu aurais été
extrêmement troublé le secteur
automobile les secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration le secteur du tourisme sont
vraiment des secteurs extrêmement
difficile où on a énormément de
démission pour pour des reconversion où
on dit vraiment dans l'hôtellerie
restauration sur touche et on se
reconvertit complètement a d'ailleurs on
le voit à autre chose par exemple de
secteur de comptabilité de dans le
secteur de l'immobilier dans le secteur
de la santé bien évidemment il y a
énormément de démission sur sur certains
secteurs où on va finalement préféré
s'occuper de la petite enfance que
des personnes âgées parce que ça a été
la crise a été extrêmement dur dans les
EHPAD et donc a donné lieu à démission
et c'est très difficile d'ailleurs de
recruter dans dans dans le secteur de
santé
en fait
de ce covit il est d'ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'il ne reprise économique donc le
variant le colis variant disparaître
sous d'un coup il y a une reprise il y a
une vraie pénurie demande aujourd'hui
dans le nombre secteur pas seulement
celui de la santé pas seulement dans le
secteur de la santé dans le secteur
aussi de l'automobile de l'aéronautique
il y a énormément de pénurie de qui sont
difficiles et de volonté encore une fois
de démission et de reconversion est le
dossier de la formation reste ouvert sur
ce sujet parce qu' est-ce que c' est
pardonnez-moi est-ce que c'est parce que
finalement aujourd'hui on ne veut plus
travailler autant qu'avant pour le même
salaire est-ce qu'il y a un
questionnement plus générale plus global
justement du fait de cette maladie de ce
virus qui fait que on travaille
peut-être pas pour les mêmes raisons
qu'il faut peut-être donner plus de sens
au travail est-ce que ça touche j'irai
la philosophie même du travail la
question il travaille donc que la
question du travail et surtout la
question de la reconnaissance au travail
a pris une beaucoup
dimension beaucoup plus importante que
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont sont dans
leurs activités sont prête à accepter
beaucoup de choses mais que d'ici un an
ou deux à mon avis et notamment les
prochaines négociation annuelle du
travail sur la question des salaires est
question de la reconnaissance la
question des rémunérations vont être des
de la transformation des entreprises et
du climat parce que la notion de climat
être extrêmement importante et rentre en
considération très très fortement auprès
des entreprises ces sujets la vont être
sans doute les les sujets de demain ils
vont permettre l'ensemble de ces sujets
donc peut-être permettre de changer
effectivement la société au niveau de la
question du travail de façon avec sa
maman en général indépendamment de celle
de l'emploi les salariés de demain sans
doute seront beaucoup plus exigeant et
et souhaite qu'on donne du sens au
travail beaucoup plus que ce que c'était
il faut faire ton palais des services
publics en l'occurrence l'hôpital la
santé est-ce que le hôpital vas réussir
à résister à ce nouveau variant au
micro-ondes même s'il effectivement
moins grave il y a tout de même des là
il y a 67000 nouveaux 4 coronavirus en
France alors c'est un chiffre bien sûr
minimiser parce qu'on est lundi mais
dans les hôpitaux la France donc annonce
3654 patient en réanimation en hausse de
82 donc ça continue à augmenter dans les
hôpitaux oui tout à fait parce que en
fait en France en fait on est bien dans
une vague de Delta toujours et c'est ça
que on a on a un peu l'impression de
dividu sujet la vague de Delta n'est pas
du tout fini en France et c'est bien des
hospitalisations essentiellement duo
complications du baril en delta est-ce
que les autres alors bien sûr c'est
cette épidémie de barrière delta est en
train d'être passé et donc bien sur la
descente doit doit être
en j'irai dans les jours qui viennent
quoi qu'il en soit est Omicron va faire
une mettre une pré mais oui sans doute
et on le voit bien au Royaume-Uni au
Danemark mais c'est une impression
modéré pourquoi parce qu'en fait les
formes grave au micro-onde son dirai
plus modéré entre guillemets qu'avec le
balai Rowenta c'est-à-dire que les gens
sont hospitalisés pour trois quatre
jours ils ont besoin de soins
hospitaliers un peu d'oxygène mais
fondamentalement il y a moins de rentrer
en réanimation et donc c'est clair que
la pression salaire réanimation une fois
que la vague sur un passer sur un
vêtement moindre avec le bar au
micro-ondes on cuit les hôpitaux ont
résisté pour autant et la question de
tous les hôpitaux en Europe ce sont les
ressources humaines pour autant que les
ressources humaines revienne rapidement
après mais dans les congés de fin
d'année et que les hôpitaux trouve des
solutions pour je dirais encadrer les
lits qui sont qui sont disponibles
vaccinal le vaccin reste la stratégie en
France en parle donc de se rappelle de
rapprocher les dates entre la deuxième
et la troisième dose est-ce qu'on va
finalement se retrouver face à un rappel
permanent à faire tous les quatre à 5
mois impose qu'on peut à quoi on peut
s'attendre
alors c'est impossible à dire
actuellement et a priori non puisque le
mardi Omicron on le voit bien et
invariant qui prend le devant sur le bac
en delta car tout petit un échappement
et militaire mais en fait qui n'est pas
plu donc c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
plutôt arriver à une situation où on
rentre dans un cycle plutôt saisonnier
de l'arrivée de nouveaux variant est
l'arrivée de nos vacances seront
toujours des gens qui seront plus
contaminant qui doivent prendre chaque
fois systématiquement le dessus sur le
vario antérieur
c'est ce que vous dites tout à fait
transmissibilité
et je pense que le
nouveau type de coronavirus alors c'est
bien pour le même
type de mutation qui rentre dans ce qui
pourrait être en tout cas un cycle
plutôt dirait de tous les 6 mois ou en
tout cas il est éventuellement a des
moments saisonnier et à ce moment-là
alors comme pour la grippe saisonnière
il faudra mets le machin ou le rappel
j'irai le plus adéquat possible par
rapport à ses nouveau mutant de ce
niveau variante qui sont plutôt intérêt
des coronavirus pas banal entre
guillemets mais en tout cas on pourra
maîtriser nettement mieux Stéphane
crochet nous a rejoint secrétaire
général du
syndicat des enseignants de l'UNSA
également professeur des écoles bonsoir
bienvenue à vous à nous notre
correspondante à Berlin également
rejoint and Bonsoir Stéphane prochaine
nouveau protocole bien sûr en cette
rentrée des classes c'était la rentrée
aujourd'hui bien sûr en France les
élèves ont repris le chemin de l'école
j'ai lu que l'absentéisme pourrais
toucher 30 % et des enseignants dans les
semaines qui viennent le protocole
sanitaire dévoilé par Jean-Michel
blancaire le mix de éducation fait que
il y a un niveau 3 maintenu dans les
écoles élémentaires et un niveau 2 dans
les collèges et lycées et il y a une
nouvelle politique de contact pressing
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il y a un
positif dans la classe doit se soumettre
à 3 3 test en 4 jours avec et en fait
ils recevront de la pharmacie Des
auto-test gratuit que pensez-vous donc
de cette de ce nouveau protocole
alors il peut s'avérer
difficile à mettre en œuvre dans la
réalité de nos classes 6e donc ce
protocole il consiste tout d'abord à
envoyer tous les élèves faire un test
PCR lorsque l'un d'eux et déjà avérés
positifs et puis peuvent revenir en
classe tous ceux qui ont un test négatif
mais ils devront faire un auto-test à J2
et à J4 et si l'un de ces test est
positif pour l'un d'entre eux alors il
devra aller le confirmer par un test PCR
et on recommence tout cette procédure
pour l'ensemble de la classe donc on
redoute on redoute la capacité
au-delà d'être fastidieux à la limite
bon fastidieux on prend son mal en
patience c'est réussir réussir à gérer
ce flot d'informations de consignes en
direction des familles le retour des
informations des familles et puis le
risque de tension parce que une fois on
va leur dire on suspend allez vous faire
tester puis on reprend mais finalement
un nouveau un nouveau cas elle s'avère
alors on recommence toute la procédure
donc voilà c'est le risque de forte
tension il y a eu d'un côté une promesse
l'école reste ouverte mais ça c'est une
bonne chose c'est la rentrée aujourd'hui
c'est une bonne chose est vraiment dans
l'absolu que l'on souhaiterait c'est
pouvoir faire classe complètement
normalement avec tous nos élèves avec
tous nos collègues parce que les
remonter les premiers remonter un de ce
premier jour c'est déjà 5 à 10 % des
élèves absents
une proportion un peu moindre mais mais
quand même assez similaire chez les
personnel donc de toute façon nous ne
sommes pas dans la vie ordinaire de
l'école et tu es le vrai climat serein
de la classe politique déteste est-elle
préférable justement à la politique
auparavant mise en place qui me semble
il me semble qu'il y avait une personne
un élève positif ont fermé la classe
était sale protocole alors ça c'est fini
depuis fin novembre
en revanche si on avait depuis fin
novembre donc au mois de décembre si
quand même en avait trois quarts positif
sur 7 jours glissants
dans la classe alors on fermait la
classe et cette dernière Jura aussi
disparu donc on a la crainte d'être dans
dans dans quelque chose de permanent et
puis et ça c'est possible typhique de
nous dire une inquiétude sur nos classes
de venant des classes
je rappelle que les élèves d'école
maternelle ne sont pas ne sont pas
masquer et ce sont en plus les plus
jeunes donc ceux qui ont le plus de mal
à respecter les gestes barrière
effectivement les classes pour devenir
des clusters avec ce type de protocole
où est-ce que justement en AR en plus
avec cette politique déteste même si
elle est complexe effectivement donc de
généraliser les tests auprès des élèves
et les professeurs est-ce que ça va
limiter justement la proportion de
contamination virus a le micro
le store comme on dit et ça passe par la
ventilation ça passe par essayer de de
fonctionner avec début du classe ou
après avoir d'autres d'autres protocole
sanitaire sur place et puis il faut
aussi peut-être changer de paradigme et
avoir moins peur je dirais
décontamination des enfants aussi avec
le micro alors c'est toujours compliqué
parce que on veut à la fin il a cassé la
chaîne de transmission et puis à la
France rencontre que la majorité bien
sûr des enfants qui sont touchés par
Omicron seront des dessins ou des formes
très très symptomatique et donc voilà
donc ça c'est c'est l'équilibre vraiment
que tu auras trouvé au mois de janvier
ou je pense qu'on peut pas laisser tout
circuler comme ça de façon sans mettre
en place des vrais protocole et il faut
des photos collées l'école mais non plus
il faut être aussi raisonnable sur des
mesures restriction de réception à la
fermeture de classe par exemple qui à
mon avis doivent être je dirais beaucoup
moins systématique avec son mari en
microbes
en direct de
l'Allemagne
passeport vaccinal et puis le port du
Mac FFP2 est très répandu en Allemagne
et manifestement ce sont des mesures qui
ont eu des résultats et lorsqu'on
regarde la carte européenne d'ailleurs
on voit que l'Allemagne n'est pas encore
touché véritablement parle au micro
alors qu'en est-il
je vous savez que l'Allemagne a été très
très dur m'en toucher parce qu'il
constitue est ici la quatrième vague de
covit à la fin de l'année dernière une
valve liés ovarian delta est le pays a
donc mise en place des mesures très
strictes assez rapidement on est revenu
au télétravail partout c'est possible de
la fin novembre le Pass sanitaire a été
instauré sur le lieu de travail pour
tous les salariés obligé de s'y rendre
et non vacciné donc avec un test
quotidien et puis le Pass vaccinal est
entré en vigueur dans les commerces dans
les restaurants dans les musées dans les
salles de spectacle un peu partout
excluant de facto les non vacciné de la
vie publique et toutes ces mesures en
tout cas elles ont eu le mérite de faire
baisser la vague de Delta et d'après les
experts également de ralentir la
propagation du variant au micro alors
pour l'instant les autorités reste 2
fois sur le qui-vive car en ce moment
les données sanitaire ne sont absolument
pas fiable en Allemagne les Allemands se
sont très peu c'est s'est ces 10
derniers jours les circonscriptions ne
font pas remonter les données vers
l'Institut de veille sanitaire et donc
résultats l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
ressemble un peu plus de 18000 nouvelles
contamination mais les autorités
sanitaires est-il que la réalité va bien
au-delà de ses chiffres on devrait
normalement avoir des chiffres en fin de
semaine mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ici aussi ce va rien se propage
lentement mais sûrement les autorités
sanitaires et Kim a plus de 10 % la
progression quotidienne du vario micro
est dans le la région du Fleckenstein
dans le nord du pays c'est d'ailleurs
déjà le variant dominant
en Allemagne dans les transports publics
c'est le cas
oui et le basket fait fait deux et très
répandue en Allemagne depuis l'année
dernière effectivement en fait ici en
Allemagne on utilise essentiellement le
masque chirurgical ou le masque FFP2 on
ne voit plus de masque en tissu depuis
fort longtemps et le masque FFP2
effectivement est devenu obligatoire
dans les transports en commun et dans
certaines régions il est même
obligatoire dans les commerces et aussi
dans quelques restaurants les autorités
encourage son utilisation et il fait
vraiment partie du quotidien et si
contrairement à la France par exemple il
faudrait justement plus généralisée ce
masque FFP2 en France pour l'instant il
n'est toujours réservé aux soignants
alors je pense qu'il faut envisager
généralisation plus important mais pas
le général généralisation de la
population générale mais bien chez les
personnes les plus les plus les plus
vulnérables toujours par rapport aux
formes grave du corps à la virus dans
les transports publics par exemple comme
ils le font en Allemagne tout à fait
alors peut-être des personnes de plus de
60 ans de plus de 70 ans de prêt
systématiquement porter un FFP2 dans
danser lieux à haut risque de
contamination mais mais non c'est
stratégie du FFP2 c'est une c'est une
politique publique ça veut dire que
c'est pas c'est pas si simple de dire
il faut une stratégie de rendre
accessible
et surtout peut-être de le rendre
disponible dans tous ses yeux je dirai à
grande folle et donc ça doit vraiment
être intégré dans une vraie politique
publique et pas simplement dire porter à
deux ça va mieux vous protège et donc
voilà je pense que ça ça pourrait être
une stratégie très intéressante en tout
cas pour dépasser cette vague de micro
Stéphane prochain vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que les profs par exemple les
instituteurs les institutrices qu'il
devrait porter ce masque
en tout cas il y a il y a la demande de
porter des masques plus protecteur que
les les masques en tissu avec lesquels
on fonctionne depuis depuis plus d'un an
notamment en raison de cette forte
transmission et cette forte présence
dans nos classes et je le redis en
particulier dans les écoles maternelles
ou nos élèves ne porte pas de masque et
puis cette question de la la qualité de
l'air aujourd'hui on le sait no no no
école son traîneau d'école et nous
établissement secondaire aussi sont
pas bons sur le sur le sujet de la
qualité de l'air et deux par exemple
mettre en place des capteurs
capteur de CO2 serait déjà le premier le
premier moyen de de mieux comprendre ce
qui se passe dans dans une salle de
classe dans une cantine aussi et quand
est-ce qu'il faut aérer ce qu'il utilise
ceux qui ont la chance d'en avoir ont
réalisé combien l'air était très vite
saturé et combien combien il fallait
aérer vite fait assez régulièrement et
de façon franche et honnête et que
souvent l'ouverture d'une seule fenêtre
dans une cantine ça ne suffit pas donc
oui on a on a beaucoup de retard on a
beaucoup de retard pour affronter cette
nouvelle vague avec ce nouveau variant
ou caractéristiques différentes et avec
une stratégie de la part du gouvernement
qui est désormais différentes aussi
justement des enfants qu'est-ce que vous
en dites vous est-ce qu'il faut vacciner
justement au maximum d'enfants
en tant qu'enseignant on ne va pas plus
loin et que ce que permet que se permet
lui-même le gouvernement désormais elle
est disponible cette vaccination on
entend dans les familles la la volonté
d'y accéder à mes mails début de juste
chez les enfants en revanche la vague
épidémie qu'elle est bien là maintenant
donc on est aussi ça fait partie des
préoccupations des enseignants ce
décalage
et aujourd'hui on a peu d'outils pour
lutter contre les épidémies dans dans
nos école maternelle et élémentaire le
la vaccination est très peu là
d'ailleurs l'accès à la troisième dose
pour les personnels et comme pour le
reste de la population dans certains
endroits assez difficile et il n'y a pas
eu d'accès prioritaire sur la qualité de
l'air en est très en dessous nos masques
sont nos masque en tissu donc on se sent
très bien très mal protégé parce
que vous allez voir on fait la guerre on
va l'écouter c'était dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale cet après-midi
notre société a donc un nouvel opium un
opium fait de doute de suspicion un
opium sûr de lui souvent arrogant qui
permet à chacun en quelques caractères
sur les réseaux sociaux d'être exemptée
d'un long cursus universitaire en
médecine alors aucun projet de loi ne
fera entendre raison à celles et ceux
pour qui le combat anti vaccinale est
devenu location d'acquérir consistance
et reconnaissance de te dire héroïque ou
résistant à peu de frais and en Autriche
en Allemagne on va passer à la
vaccination obligatoire dans quelques
semaines en Autriche me semble-t-il et
dans quelques mois en Allemagne on a
réussi à faire passer ça dans ces deux
pays
écouter les débats sont encore en cours
et des décisions au niveau des
parlements sont en 40 attendu en
Autriche qui veut effectivement faire
entrer en vigueur cette obligation
vaccinale dès le mois de février avec
une obligation vaccinale donc pour tous
les plus de 14 ans et des amendes allant
jusqu'à 3600 € pour tous ceux qui refuse
de se soumettre alors un certain nombre
de débat sont encore en cours à Vienne
notamment en ce qui concerne la mise en
œuvre de cette obligation vaccinale et
des interrogations aussi sur la marche à
suivre mais a priori ça devrait se faire
dans les semaines qui viennent et
l'Allemagne devrait très vite ensuite
emboîter le pas l'autre il fait ce que
le nouveau chancelier Olaf Scholz et
effectivement favorable à cette
obligation vaccinale alors c'est lié au
fait que on a le mal le taux de
vaccination reste encore à ses fables un
comparé à des pays comme la France avec
à peine un peu plus de 71 % de la
population qui est doublement vacciné
mais cette population non vacciné elle
est bien évidemment susceptible de faire
des formes plus graves de la maladie une
fois contaminé c'est ce que les
autorités venez vite et on en sort en
cette obligation vaccinale et qui est
intéressant c'est que après près de 2
ans de pandémie la grande majorité des
Allemands deux tiers des Allemands sont
désormais favorable à cette obligation
vaccinale alors que il y a 2 ans lorsque
cette pandémie a commencé c'était la
situation inverse de Thiers les
Allemands étaient opposés à une
obligation vaccinale il faut faire un
peu la chasse aux antivax aujourd'hui
quelle leçon peut-on tirer
ah ça c'est une question politique vous
me demandez moi je suis un scientifique
et je n'ai aucun avis par rapport à ça
je pense qu'il faut essayer de
convaincre celles et ceux qui ne qui ont
besoin d'une vaccination et qui sont
toujours hésitant mais qui sont à risque
de faire des efforts mais ça c'est une
réalité et à chaque pays de trouver la
bonne stratégie sur un plan politique il
y a qu'un paradoxe crème dans dans tout
ce que vous échanger par rapport à cette
obligation c'est que d'un côté les
ministres nous disent ils ont raison
avec la bague Omicron on est en train de
dépasser je dirais je dirais La Flambée
du coronavirus on est en train de
dépasser j'irai c'est pour 10 minutes à
l'échelle en tout cas nationale les
formes sont plus bénigne on développe
une unité aussi passe par rapport au
baril en tant que tel et puis d'un autre
côté ils durcissent le ton sur les non
vacciné au sur les
obligations vaccinales de cohérence oui
attention au tsunami de ce qui nous
arrive dans notre côté on me dit mais
non c'est la dernière vague ça y est
rassuré il est limité collective on y
arrive donc voilà je pense que il faut
aussi que le discours politique
redevienne plus cohérent par rapport aux
connaissances scientifiques parce que
d'un côté on utilise les connaissances
scientifiques pour justifier les choses
et d'un autre côté je dirais on ne les
restaurants on sort dirait de ses
connaissances pour justifier l'autre
chose et là je pense qu'il y a un retour
vers la cohérence qui doit être plus
fait même si j'ai bien conscience que le
discours et l'avion politique est bien
différent de certains scientifiques mais
quand même ça doit être basée sur des
connaissances actualiser merci beaucoup
il propriétaire d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup également à Stéphanie
Matuidi qui était avec nous en première
partie Gwendoline de Bono à quelqu'un
avec nous d'Israël merci Anna en direct
de Berlin merci aussi à Stéphane crochet
secrétaire général du S
merci à vous tous d'avoir suivi et reste
avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]